so on the crypto side obviously you guys
read it as a noun storeroom oh the years
what when he token what are these rumors
say well here's what I'll say uh I
probably more than most understand
there's certain things you can say you
can't say exception maybe just talk
about crypto within the reddit system
why something other than Bitcoin it was
Bitcoin ever considered they just got
whatever you're comfortable staying
there so I I have to unfortunately keep
very mum about this what I can say is
the thing you know we we had had read at
the company had had some forays into
crypto and some of your Twitter people
had remarked on this when I came back in
14 as executive chair there were some
forays into it but it was mostly still
research we had much more pressing
things to handle at that point much more
pressing things and like for instance we
didn't have a mobile team or plan or
anything like it was more important in
2014 that ready to have a mobile app and
a mobile website and that we were
building towards that for instance but I
have always believed the long-term value
of Reddit is not gonna come from
traditional from advertising it will
come from the fact that we've already
done the hardest part we have managed to
build a platform that handles tens of
thousands of communities and hundreds of
millions of users who truly have a sense
of community and belonging with one
another and we know and a lot of this
was inadvertent frankly like we didn't
have a grand vision in five to do this
but we watched it happen and I had a
front-row seat as we were like I was the
first community manager for our first
ten communities I would just post links
under different user names and moderate
submissions so everyone stayed on sort
of task and subject and we've watched
whether it's digital goods in gaming
right I want to buy a skin so I look
nice for myself and for my friends and
for strangers right there's no I mean
there's a small tribe there of like
people you know and then people you'll
randomly sort of shoot and walk away
from in the video game
but on reddit people are people will buy
pizzas for strangers people have such a
much stronger tribal spirit and
community spirit that if you could take
the best lessons learned from digital
goods and gaming things like tipping on
Twitch or patreon and provide a very
seamless digital transaction for that it
will happen it will happen a lot and
like even awards the first version of
Reddit Awards I'm modeled after the
awards at the end of Goldeneye where
you'd have some that made sense and you
have these others like random like RC
p90 award I forget there was some random
and like we didn't really have I don't
even know if we ever looked it up we
would have used HotBot I don't know we
wouldn't have googled it back then but
like we we liked as gamers we really
like this idea of oh you get this award
if you do certain good things over the
course of a day and that was just for
you on and that was like 2006 so before
any of this award stuff gamification any
that stuff was a thing we did it just
because we were copying Goldeneye and
what I wish we had done was double down
on it back then because what we're
already seeing now even with small
modest improvements towards that users
love giving them to one another they
love subreddits communities love
creating them it reinforces this
tribalism and the more that we can do to
help communities and users strengthen
their relationships to one another and
make money in a way that they're happy
with like the more we win and and it
just seems like a logical transition
then if we know I just gave you the
horizon experience with Skye Weaver
right if we know this stuff works where
you don't have any ownership whatsoever
and it's a massive industry and growing
it reasons it reasons to be that if you
allow for a kind of ownership and and a
kind of decentralization to it that
people would do it even more because
they can feel all the fields we get when
we you know take a cup and say hey do
you want this cup here you go so and
then may not not have this company more
of course
and so I wish I could tell you more
about it I love the fact that there is
this much energy here and and I do think
long-term a big part of my job on the
board especially right now while you
know Redditt traffic like every UGC site
is booming we can reasonably all expect
marketing dollars to soften and and so
now is the time for companies like
Reddit to double down on revenue streams
that are like this that are a creative
that are things that build on community
dynamics that actually add value to
everyone involved and and and as sue the
sort of traditional models of marketing
or at least you know remove our reliance
on them as a business yeah